[Musik]
er selber mit so übt heuer auf das
jeweilige wesentlich drei punkte das ist
einerseits erhaltung der schießt und
fertige messen in 70 meter vor die
personenkontrolle durch suche von
personen ab fünf personen waren von
personen und zwei schwerpunkte beim
thema schutz und drittens eingebettete
eine kleine lage wo sie am schützen
hilfesuchende personen geht ein reales
thema was wird ihr zu euren österreicher
leben die festigung unserer fertigkeiten
man einer prüfung
erstmals wird das sein milizverband
evaluiert und teilbereichen das
pilotprojekt für die zukunft damit ihr
wissen wo stehen wir
und worauf müssen wir aufbauen und
besser werden zu können um fit für den
einsatz zu sehen
[Musik]
kameradschaft ist eigentlich das was
ausmacht
das kann man für mich eine große rolle
weil weil es einfach wichtig ist in der
gruppe und man hilft nur einen zum
anderen aus einer nicht gemacht der
andere kameradschaft lernt man so
richtig kennen das beim bundesheer und
merkten dann erst das ist was das
bedeutet das für ein gefühl das ist und
so was findet man sonst sehr selten
eigentlich und privatleben hier sieht
das jeder partie in zwei und
[Musik]